OFFICIAL WHO TOLD ME THAT KIM'S
REGIME IS WAR MONGERING AND
MAKING GESTURES THAT ARE
AGGRAVATING TENSIONS ON THE
PENINSULA.
>> ARTILLERY BARRAGE.
COMMANDOS PARACHUTE IN, TAKE
POSITIONS AROUND COLUMNS AS THE
BUILDING BURNS.
THESE ARE NORTH KOREAN SPECIAL
FORCES.
THEIR TARGET, A MOCKUP OF SOUTH
KOREA'S BLUE HOUSE, THEIR
VERSION OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> I THINK THIS SHOULD BE A
WAKEUP CALL TO THE SOUTH KOREAN
GOVERNMENT AND THE SOUTH KOREAN
PEOPLE THAT YOU HAVE A NORTH
KOREA WHICH IS STILL BENT ON THE
POTENTIAL DESTRUCTION OF THE
SOUTH.
>> THE TROOPS PRACTICE CAPTURING
AN ENEMY WHO THEY SAY NEEDS TO
BE PUT ON TRIAL.
THIS DRILL WAS PERSONALLY
DIRECTED BY THE COUNTRY'S
DICTATOR, KIM JONG-UN.
EXPERTS SAY KIM'S FORCES HAVE
GOOD INTELLIGENCE ON THE LAYOUT
OF THE SOUTH KOREAN LEADER'S
RESIDENCE.
>> HERE WE SEE A VERY WELL
DETAILED REPRODUCTION OF THE
BLUE HOUSE.
WE HAVE THE MAIN FACILITY HERE,
THE TWO AUXILIARY BUILDINGS AND
EVEN THE CARPORT AND EVEN THE
UNIQUE PATTERN OF SIDEWALK IN
FRONT OF THE BUILDING.
THEY PAID VERY CLOSE ATTENTION
TO DETAIL WHEN THEY BUILT THIS.
>> THE NORTH KOREANS HAVE STAGED
AN ACTUAL ATTACK ON THE BLUE
HOUSE, JANUARY 1968.
ARMED WITH THESE WEAPONS,
DRESSED IN SOUTH KOREAN
UNIFORMS, THEY GOT TO WITHIN 350
FEET OF THE BLUE HOUSE.
IN A FURIOUS GUN BATTLE, AT
LEAST 30 SOUTH KOREANS WERE
KILLED, AS WELL AS 29 NORTH
KOREAN COMMANDOS.
ONE NORTH KOREAN ATTACKER WHO
WAS CAPTURED SPOKE TO CNN.
>> I CAME TO KILL THE PRESIDENT.
>> IT WAS A MISSION THAT FAILED.
AND THAT LEADER'S DAUGHTER IS
THE COUNTRY'S PRESIDENT.
SHE'S JUST BEEN IMPEACHED IN A
POLITICAL SCANDAL, HAS HAD HER
POWER TAKEN AWAY.
EXPERTS SAY KIM JONG-UN WILL USE
THE SOUTH KOREAN CRISES, THE
POLITICAL INSTABILITY, TO HIS
ADVANTAGE.
>> THEY CONTINUE TO HAVE A
POLITICAL PARALYSIS, IT COULD BE
VERY DIFFICULT TO DEAL WITH
NORTH KOREAN PROVOCATION.
WE SHOULD KEEP IN MIND THAT
NORTH KOREA DOES HAVE A VERY
SAVVY SENSE FOR DRAMA.
THEY WILL BE TRYING TO GET ON A
RADAR OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> IT APPEARS TONIGHT KIM
JONG-UN'S ALREADY ON THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT'S RADAR.
DONALD TRUMP TELLING FOX NEWS HE
NEEDS MORE HELP IN PRESSURING
PYONGYANG.
>> YOU HAVE NORTH KOREA, NUCLEAR
WEAPONS AND CHINA COULD SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM AND THEY'RE NOT
HELPING US AT ALL.
>> EXPERTS SAY CHINA IS FED UP
WITH KIM JONG-UN.
THEY ARE TIRED OF HIS NUCLEAR
TESTS AND OTHER PROVOCATIONS.
THEY'RE ANGRY WITH HIM FOR NOT
TELLING THEM ABOUT THOSE TESTS
BEFOREHAND, AND THE CHINESE ARE
PUNISHING HIM.